hey what's up guys welcome to another
episode of hey hey [ __ ] I still don't
know how to enjoy I feel like we've had
plenty of time to work on that no we did
it I don't know if it's hey [ __ ] or if
it's habit or if it's like hey it's okay
that's all just okay so a really quick
roll call
this is Gio I have I'm Gina uh I'll
introduce you last beause jess is here
Jessica might come out though oh yeah
okay it's Jessica when she's feeling
feisty right yeah okay and we have
special guest my Prima that's my cousin
but not really my cousin but I wish it
was my cousin 404 okay yeah thank you
Stacy Diaz apple.com Warren
Prima is banished for cousin yes exactly
prima learning FEMA all right and today
we're gonna talk about something really
exciting we're gonna talk about when you
meet someone for the you guys are on a
date the cliquish is happening you guys
are vibing you guys are full-on each
other it's about the end of the night
you guys are filling each other still
and you're like [ __ ] I don't want this
to end
are you guys [ __ ] on the first date
or not you went from real romantic to
like wow it doesn't have to be romantic
it could just be just just a [ __ ]
hook do you have to be on a date or can
even like on a bender can you just like
see someone you know like random in the
shower read up like in a bit of more I
got a dive like a one-night stand
oh my god is like written okay so I
don't know you're not weird okay go
ahead yeah we support you wait can we do
a roll call of who who has [ __ ] on the
first date or not yes
let's read a play all right [ __ ]
exposures that all right alright
starting from Jess I think it's quite
clear that for me yes yeah so jess has
[ __ ] on the first date
both bows
absolutely not absolutely it's not even
just uh no it's like absolutely [ __ ]
not I'm a nun yeah I have yes bro lacy
my got a party my current boyfriend
though I'm just I'm gonna yeah okay I
did yeah are you I felt like I knew from
the beginning I was like [ __ ] I'm
gonna end up marrying this guy [ __ ]
oh my god yeah it was scary no it's a
lot of pressure okay Gio right here um
no absolutely [ __ ] not no real talk
her life is lame no but real talk
I regret that [ __ ] yeah okay okay well I
want to be a little I want to be a
little freaky as I said about what deep
accounts this is Gina
and surprisingly despite how I looked
you look beautiful also a nice she has
Ho energy cool though yeah yeah you have
whole energy but you look very sweet
thank you yeah but I have the I have the
crazy stories but surprisingly I've
never [ __ ] on the first date wow I'm
amazing
Yeah right surprising people in the
comments can be like you [ __ ] liar
yeah whatever but no dude I've never
[ __ ] on the first date before because
so second date or maybe wait three
months once no that's okay that's my
usual three months yeah bro minimum hmm
I I just can't relate to that do you
think you're gonna live forever why are
you yelling get your a little bit you
wait three months you filled their car
yeah well here this is why I regret it
though um it's I I've only been in
long-term relationships that only had
[ __ ] I've haven't been in a relationship
after I've been married but um let me
see you hold on give me give me a little
bit 18 so I've only had four
relationships okay they've all been
long-term no less than three years Wow
yeah yeah so because and I didn't even
when I dated it was like I had to wait
to know this person for at least like a
few months before I even went on a date
I can't even commit to a birth control
that long that's a help thank you that
you make people wait three months to I
tried it once so
and it was a huge regret did you small
oh my god yes and did you feel like were
you like I want to do it so so bad but
I'm holding myself back yeah I just
don't have that kind of self-control I
really don't like life ashore and uh if
he looks good and I look good like
what's the problem
you know life goes on so to me I was
just always like I like you and you like
me so why not yeah you know uh well for
me it's a little bit different because I
was raised very Catholic and by very
Catholic I don't mean like I'm going to
church every single Sunday but my mom
had that very like small-town mind yeah
a girl can't be out past 10:00 or if she
would look at a girl on the street that
was dressed showing a little bit more
skin hope she needed to then she's up
she's a ho like you don't want to be
associated to that like so I just had
all these like I was just really
conditioned growing up so just having
these thoughts of like man I want to
[ __ ] I want to think I felt so guilty
that I'm like I don't like I don't ever
want to be that girl I don't want to go
I don't want guys talking about me like
yeah I hate that you know I don't that's
why now I'm like Bob you wish you would
have done it yeah cuz you learned so
much about yourself you learn more about
like how to connect you know with your
significant other um it doesn't make you
a hoe yeah you're learn what you like I
think my reasons a lot less holy because
my reason like how just saying like
sometimes you meet someone in a bar used
to home with them
my reason of never having a one-night
stand is because I am desperately and
tear of like just absolutely terrified
of getting raped in murder yeah I'm
terrified yeah yeah so like I'm crazy
about that so when people say like yeah
I'm gonna go to the bar and hook up with
some people I'm like dude aren't you
afraid like I might get murdered or yeah
sort of s CD or something sigh I just
could never do that until I really get
to know them and find out their address
and their names and then I'm comfortable
to [ __ ] them because that I can come
after them afterwards I mean I usually
just like get the address cuz I know
where I'm going right I'm like oh I'm at
whatever 6th Street downtown at this you
know [ __ ] apartment I'm in apartment
307 and I take that to somebody and then
as long as yes it just sends the pin
come on I'm howand no no no not my own
address house I'm like I'll send my
address to a friend and I'm like dude I
was re good I mean I was just saying for
me I was kind of like geo and that like
I was raised very very Christian like my
parents were like there are no penises
there none but also the other thing is
you know I said previously like in
another podcast that I was very like
kind of like asexual early on like I
always use sex as a means to like I was
like oh this is how a guy will like me
and I mean I don't think like that
anymore but I'm just being [ __ ] real
and you know guys you'll encounter girls
like this and you won't know and girls a
lot of you feel that way like you're
just not a particularly sexual person so
for me when it came down to it I was
like what do I get out of this yeah like
I don't wanna [ __ ]
so when you say asexual do you mean that
you never had any sort of attraction for
anyone or you just want interested in
sex I wasn't I didn't I did not enjoy
sex because in order for me to have good
sex I had to have a deep emotional
connection right buddy yeah and you know
I I cannot have that on the first night
yeah there's actually a word for that
not asexual but there's something where
you have to have an emotional connection
with someone yeah enjoy it and I never
had good sex until I started dating -
dude I'm dating now like it was trash it
was all trash dig I think I feel like I
have the best sex with someone I'm not
super emotionally yeah interesting
because it's like rhonchi er yes it's
yes I feel it um like at one point like
there was a guy that was dating that was
like I'm not really into you anymore I
think I'm awesome open for a threesome
you want to bring another yeah we never
did but like you know like one I'm not
that emotionally attached like you're
not mine anymore I'm like yeah I'm like
missus like I hear all these stories and
I feel like I'm missing out like Jess
can you walk me through yeah what that's
like you see someone how does that
happen
no you just start talking okay like I
guess in the club or if you're on the
edge my house gets barbecue
so to catch you up that's what she
deemed Joe her now boyfriend he deemed
me first okay but then it ended and I'm
within a month I asked him to have sex
with me but in that way you want to you
want to fly okay I didn't want to [ __ ]
Joe on the first night okay Joe is like
boyfriend material
first night material first night
material is like the hottest guys you've
ever seen but you know they're [ __ ]
yeah but you know they got money a
Michael Jordan what's up this [ __ ] a tea
and then you don't want to talk to them
ever again because they're gonna
completely ruin your self-esteem they're
gonna ruin your life when you gotta get
in and get out oh my god I've been okay
I'm faithful I'm just saying but like
for some reason for the past month or so
like sometimes I'll see guys and I'm
like oh you look like you would ruin my
[ __ ] dude there are some guys that
like I'm like you are gonna break my
yeah yeah let's just do this one yeah
yeah how long have you been with your
current boyfriend me yeah over a year so
do you think it's already like to the
point where you're like oh that looks
interesting yeah that looks Wow no I'm
not think you ever would but I my
boyfriend is amazing and he's very like
I boyfriend material he's a boyfriend
sweater material that's fair there's
okay even for guys they understand this
there's wifey material
and then there's supermodel hi and you
know she's not wifey material she's just
like I want to [ __ ] she's bad you some
and to others that's their wife you know
that's fair that's yeah but well for me
personally like yeah there dude there
have been like some guys lately where
I'm like oh my god I was like in only in
my youth I'm like man lost opportunities
but like I'm happy where I am now
yeah yeah I feel like if I were to [ __ ]
you on the first date that means I don't
respect like I don't respect you like
I'm [ __ ] you on the first date
because I know I'm not gonna marry you
so like I don't want to date you I just
want to [ __ ] you and that's it so like
guys think that same thing yeah yeah
right yeah I don't know a lot of times
not all of them but like I can't relate
because both of my serious relationships
it was literally that the first time
yeah you know and so one
I meant like at the gym and you know
like he was actually one of our clients
I used to be a CrossFit coach and you
know like he was our client well it was
the second time I met him he was the key
you want to come hang out at the house
and I was like yeah that's fine and then
it ended up happening oh you know yeah
but then that turned into a meaningful
relationship that actually lasted for a
long time that was very deep and like a
really deep connection for me and so
when we like broke up and like we still
kind of had that relationship going on
we're like I will always love you kind
of love and I would ask him like why do
we have sex that first time he was like
well it didn't matter to me like I felt
like we were already so connected and I
liked you and you liked me and that's
never gonna make me think any less of
you
just because you opened up yourself to
me like no woman and I feel like society
like tell says like oh you hold
something special like you're not
supposed to give it away your pretty
flower yeah but in reality like [ __ ] we
all like sex like I want to come you
want to commit like what here's I get
that and I respect that and that's a
part of me that goes back and forth with
like [ __ ] I should have done it in my
youth but then the other part of me is
like and not to put anyone down at this
table at all because I'm I think you
guys are [ __ ] badass but it's like
you're letting something insert itself
in you gonna mean one way don't you wait
wait wait wait just kidding six hey you
got a busted Mariah Carey okay when she
hits that I know she back
my levels are different than y'all's
because I can barely hear you oh yeah
you know what I actually I gotta say
like there's like orange chopping but it
is annoying I really like that we're a
group of like all very very opinionated
people with diverse opinions yeah like
we can all sit down and be like oh I
think this I think I think you're a ho I
don't think anyone's at home like I
don't shame on that but everyone thinks
I'm a ho well not you guys you guys know
me better oh yeah yeah but for me when I
start thinking about stuff that's why
I'm like you where I have to have this
deep connection cuz then I'm just like I
don't know what your dicks been like I
know you're gonna be in me like [ __ ]
yeah and I could say that like for
example and Beau said like I think it
was you said it like I felt like I was
giving myself away because that was the
only way I was gonna be loved I think in
a way I felt that you know and not until
I got into this recent relationship
where I have truly felt loved and I just
use for my body do I really feel like oh
you know what like I kind of regret some
of the people I allowed to be in my
energy you know and I think that there's
a middle ground between yeah I tried it
and it was cool and like I shouldn't
have [ __ ] done all that you know but
I think you're living you learn and a
lot of the times like the way I am at
least I have always experimented you
know so something I really like about
Bart like bar will we say I want to try
things just to see how they feel and I
feel in a way I did that with
relationships you should see this [ __ ]
then he says you know I mean I don't
know about all that but like I want to
hold a man's heart dick I mean I feels
like it's not that great but I mean whoa
so pretty great in the middle but no I
mean just to like put you guys into like
some perspective like there was a point
before I got into my relationship where
I was like I'm gonna date on tinder just
to see what kind of people are out there
and I'm gonna date like for content
almost like I'm gonna date to see and
not like oh like YouTube videos like no
but just to experience the things that
are out there and experience the kind of
people that are out there and I wasn't
[ __ ] everybody but I was meaning the
different people I met and it was just
crazy the emotional roller coaster I
would go on and then experiencing that
and then give me some examples give me
some examples so for example
I would be like okay why do I always get
attached to people okay so then I would
go with someone who I didn't think that
was attractive and then I would be like
that I get attached to this you know I
didn't okay so why do I owe you didn't
see that no I mean it's just different
people but like for example there was a
point where like after every date I
would feel like some sort of sadness
right and I would be like why am i sad
like what is it about this that makes me
feel so empty and I realized that every
time I was going on a date I was going
with the hopes that it would turn into
something meaningful and so when I
didn't turn into something meaningful it
would be heartbreaking and so I realized
that every time I was dating looking for
that relationship that loved the feeling
that hi and it wasn't Matt because it's
not gonna be met with everyone you mean
though I would be so devastated you know
and I think I never would have known
that about myself if I wouldn't have
done all that I did and as you guys know
like I enjoy empowering women and I
enjoy like giving them dating advice and
I enjoy like feelings and emotions and
it was almost like research purposes
with myself you know it just kind of
made me realize like this is gonna like
sound so [ __ ] wack so I feel really
valid I'm gonna laugh at you like oh my
god you're so ready
like I like literally like my whole life
since I was a kid like oh my god where
the cry glasses okay really I got some I
got okay okay but like you know like I
grew up I grew up like single family
home like no dad no nothing and I felt
like I was lacking love for a lot of my
life so I spent a lot of time searching
for love in relationships and I like
even as a kid I would watch like
romantic comedies
I love romantic comedies and I always
wanted to like fall in love like really
and so for me I couldn't have sex with
somebody because I'm like well I'm not
gonna marry you so like and it's it's
almost a little like close-minded but
also at the same time like I was so
desperate for this love and like I
didn't want to waste my time I don't
wanna waste your time like I want [ __ ]
you you know like I just really wanted
to be like in love yeah can I actually
can every check what I said earlier
about how like if I [ __ ] in the first
day that means I don't respect you
yeah sorry no I do respect you
I just might not want to be in
relationship with you but I do respect
you because I first date I don't wanna I
don't know Coleman's coming after me
alright
yeah it's [ __ ] the first date I
respect the show a lot of my
relationships started with the one-night
stand so oh I want to get to that I
might think that but I don't I want to
get to that but first we're gonna take a
quick break to hear from our sponsors
dingdong [ __ ] can't get laid
how about some food straight to your
door order enough food and you don't
even have to pay a delivery fee and on
top of that us here at hey [ __ ] are
giving you five dollars off Gina what's
that code the code is b tch I'm scared
please don't yell at me yeah definitely
I use this all the time since I have a
baby now it's really hard for me to
leave sometimes snapping it's very
inconvenient time for me to leave it go
get food or even make food so I always
hit up door - so you don't cook you a
bad mother okay I use it when I complete
nights playing video games and I don't
want to go out and buy any things so
they send me food and I can feel I feel
like a further degenerate than I am
right now that's right if you're like me
and you don't like to exercise or pick
up the phone you don't have to walk it
is a little bit when I have to go and
open the front door but that's okay
because this is real life and you get
what you get but you know what it's at
your door it's hot it's fresh it's
delicious and we've got it for you with
code BT CH download the app and use the
code b-tch at checkout you won't regret
it
okay we're back all right just what were
you say yeah I think actually when I
look back to most of my relationships I
think I slept with them very very fast
so I don't think I in my head I'm like
oh yeah if I sleep with you right away
then that means I already know we're not
gonna do anything I think that's just
like a protective thing because I'm like
well if it does I'm still okay with it
but if yeah I feel that it's fine do you
have interesting do you have a healthy
relationship with your dad yes and no
okay I had no relationship with my mom
yeah and I think if if anyone like mommy
issues might be a thing for the future
because like I don't know if it's the
same or not but like I have a healthy
relationship with men I love men I'm so
straight like I love gay men I want to
watch game and have sex like I'm all
about men I love men so much but Wes is
the least lesbian one in our yeah
jess is violently stretching Superman I
love men so much but yeah I don't know I
don't feel like even if I do a ton of
self-reflecting I don't feel like I was
having sex on the first date because I
wanted love so badly I just felt like it
was fun yeah and then a lot of my
relationships came from that too anyway
so it's like I don't know so you're like
me I don't need an emotional test yeah I
don't know it's just a physical thing
it's like good it's like it's like going
out to party like when you go out to
party you have a different energy on you
go out to the club if you start popping
bottles like you're feeling a different
way about yourself and that's just what
that's the energy that I would be in if
I was sleeping with someone like on the
first time I'm like I feel I feel
feeling myself you know I want to [ __ ] I
want to like go [ __ ] go into this
club bathroom and pull my pants down I
would do it okay so question we're not
judging though
yeah I love it which is poor you this is
funny to you because I feel like Stacy's
like the medium between like all of us
she's like I don't know pyramid but I
want love okay so question are you like
what is sex for you like is it just a
good time does it feel good is it good
Wow you know I mean or is it to you a
way to express your love yes and it
shouldn't be supplied to you do you feel
like even when you have sex with you
even your current partner do you feel
like I slept it doesn't matter if I
finish as long as I'm giving you my body
yes yes when I was having nice for years
and nobody I'm smarter [ __ ] no no but
like there was no there was no orgasm
there was no none of that you know I own
I feel bad for you girl none and that
and never experienced and I met you so
many girls can relate cuz so many girls
are probably younger and are like who
cares as long as he's enjoying it and my
body's being used it doesn't matter if I
feel pleasure yes my ass was like do you
love me
no not my bottle me as a whole my brain
our experiences of sex are so opposite
yeah I'm like what can make me come
first yeah hope not a one-night stand
and I feel that you know and I think
that's dope that you have that deep like
sense of self love because at the end of
the day a lot of us are striving for
that because with sex but like in my
life like in other ways I don't think I
have a lot of self-love because I'm
self-conscious about a lot of things but
then when it comes to sex I'm like yeah
dominate and if you're gonna [ __ ] get
me dude look at slap your like crazy
crazy
oh my god dawn she just demands what she
would you were like I'm gonna come first
so I'm still trying to live vicariously
through Jess's past like can you please
watch happen how does it happen from one
guy yes this one guy from so this one
guy I said it turned into like a like a
constant fuck-buddy thing was he I
thought what if you look at pilot he's
an Air Force pilot and so obviously I'm
like no tell me I'm thinking Top Gun Tom
Cruise you got aviator sunglasses
leaking not so so yeah okay Val Kilmer
oh my I spend all those guys are ugly
biggest crush on [ __ ] Val Kilmer in
that movie you're old you [ __ ] you were
trailing right if I can really close
behind ok I'm telling y'all after this
episode there's about to be like some
hot jack dudes and Jess's diem just a
blip no I have a man get out of my deal
so yeah we trying to think of the first
night I feel like the first time I met
him so we were just talking at the at a
bar or whatever it's like one of those
bars it's like videogames and beer you
know look yeah dive bars yeah so they
have like all this stuff so anyway so
we're talking hanging out and then like
I give him my number or whatever and
then I kiss him and then we left so that
wasn't the exact same night but the very
next night I saw him and then we [ __ ]
on the first night we went to a hotel
immediately had sex like you guys dinner
yeah we went to dinner and then we had
sex like immediately afterward I like I
was so attracted to him like a
like he was so hot but I was like he's
like airforce like pilots [ __ ] everybody
so I know I'm not gonna die you're never
scared like I might get some [ __ ] like
if he's tested it like you don't think
that [ __ ] I don't hoc book myself I
don't think about AIDS that much in life
so I think we used a condom anyway I'm
surprised you went on a date with
someone in the military and didn't he
didn't propose to you the first night oh
no the pilot pilots are hard to tie down
pilots are alcoholics and their
womanizers oh my god they [ __ ] good so
anyway yeah so then that just turned
into like we would see each other every
time he was in town cuz he's obviously a
pilot so he's not always in town but
whenever he would he would be in town
we'd be in Austin we [ __ ] everywhere
dude we pucked and we [ __ ] in a
parking garage we [ __ ] in a park
we [ __ ] like everywhere in a minute
Club bathroom like all over the all of
us and we're just you know it would be
like that would be a heat map it would
just be like pull pull on like red all
over the city of Austin military things
go out there you brought me with them
you know do it okay you know you're
scared of STDs too right yeah we're all
scared until I got like um so this was
like almost two years ago when I moved
to LA I was like dude I was like I'm
gonna break this habit like because you
know what I've been really open eyed
like about how I'm looking for love I'm
just enjoying it like and I'm
recognizing that like that's not the
best position to be in but I'm just
being honest that's where I was you know
um so I made this pact with my friend we
were like we're not gonna date for a
year because when you know you're not
dating it takes away the prospect of
what's this gonna together yeah that was
my exercise and so I was like great no
dating until June first
and so I get on tinder - that was it
would that that was the date one year so
I get on tender and like I meet this guy
and he's very my type like he's tall
blonde has a bunch of tattoos like soup
Ethan was so hot like but like yeah he
was super hot and like we went I can't
remember where we went we went somewhere
for like the first day and like I really
liked him and I was like all right
I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do it but it
wasn't first date I was I was ready on
the second date I was [ __ ] ready good
for you it's so 24 hours after she was
already later and he was like let's go
to Six Flags and I was like yeah great
and he was like okay meet at my house so
I don't want a six legs girl so well
that's we were taking the uber or
whatever from Six Flags and one of his
friends it's gonna come I [ __ ] get
there and it's this big house like up
like when you're like going up the hill
oh we [ __ ] well I know right well we
[ __ ] there's there's a couple daddy
is four oh there's four roommates and
it's a really really nice place and
there's a plaque on the wall and it's
like welcome to Woodland Hills rehab the
rehab said come to my house into rehab
yes it was a rehab center and his
grandma had put him there and she had
given him a card to like pay for
everything and like we still went to Six
Flags and he was all over me like we're
in the back he like had his head in my
lap and I was like I can't do this
because I was scared like what cuz if
you're in rehab house like like you
might have lived a crazy [ __ ] life
sure you know and you're still in the
process of healings yeah exactly like
that's more the thing is you shouldn't
be dating and STDs well because I was
like I was I was like going that day I
was like about to be down and then
although I mean there's a judgement told
me or would you guys have been like I
don't know look at intuition yeah it's
one of those things where it's like I'm
not gonna [ __ ] him on the first night
but why am i shaving my [ __ ] right now
a drug addict so I probably would have
done [ __ ] cat told me that he told me
that he was the manager of the rehab
home no you're [ __ ] not now with that
spider web tattoo
so many guys with spider web tattoo sort
of go oh my god I was like no you
should've just [ __ ] him it was
probably it probably would have been
your only good sex after a while well he
also shared a room with somebody in the
manager Oh dodged a bullet there and
then I was like you know what I'm not
gonna do this do you know what we gonna
say yeah what I say oh I don't know you
we're trying to say something oh no I
was saying how like yeah well you say
you're not gonna [ __ ] on the first date
but you're sitting there shaving your
[ __ ] at the same time yeah you're like
just in case somebody sees it yeah you
put on your cutest underwear yeah if I
shave I'm [ __ ] I'm not wasting that
energy I'm not gonna waste that energy I
did that though every time just in case
just in case I ever did or like have you
ever like not shaved to keep yourself I
was like they'll deal with it I really
thought it was like tricking myself like
really winning right now I really I
don't have an option now because now I
lasered no hair likes to nothing like I
ain't got no hair on this pussycat so
I'm ready all the times that I have no
barrier holding me back I'm gonna flex
on it - yeah yeah let me hear about
yours like how so I feel like I don't
know at least Latina women yeah we have
like this stigma right because already
Latinos are like known to be machismo
and I want like their chick to be kind
of beneath them it seems like you're not
weird how did you get past that though
oh I don't know it's really weird
because okay so uh I don't know if who
knows but who cares I will grew up in
Mexico till I was 13 and so over there
it was very much like how you guys were
saying like yeah you're you're supposed
to be with one man and you're supposed
to wait till you're married and this is
the only man you're ever gonna be with
and it's really weird to think about
because when I came here yeah I can
imagine I mean I can't relate and so
when I got here I got here when I was 13
so my teen years were here so I think
I'm that weird mixture like of a true
Mexican American you know like I truly
have the values of a Mexican
who grew up over there but then as a
teenager you are exposed to so much here
like you guys are so advanced like 15
year-olds are [ __ ] over there I can't
really I just wanna let you know right
now since geo won't do it I just watched
cocoa for the first time yesterday can
you please put on your old friend I'm
not putting please put me on your friend
I don't want to be for all my God thank
you I'll put you in my own friend back
thank you
my fake-ass friend she'll won't put me
on her she keeps adding hi are you
[ __ ] happy now we're nice button out
of all people to go that I meet the
first day puts me on her girlfriend that
thanks Jill was enough friend no that's
what we do in the other los muertos so
like a of the dead yeah the day of the
dead so we put the ball car would like
all of our families pictures my brother
dead yeah is on there they can bet you
know that sugar schools early yeah
popular like we put them there for them
for them to like eat and have food even
though they passed away so in the movie
Coco they like come back and visit them
only visit us only if we have their
picture up yeah yeah and Gio won't put
me up she wants me in the effort like
absolutely not absolutely okay finish
yeah you have the belly I mean so I feel
like I have both mixtures but when I got
here I really got into like the whole
like women have rights thing and then I
don't know like I just felt really
empowered and I felt like maybe it has
to do like how jess was saying like i
had such a great relationship with my
dad but not so much with women because
her mom wasn't around
when my dad felt our household I feel
like I have such a great relationship
with women like I have great friendships
with them I was in relationships with
them for a while like it just was so a
sexual relationship yeah like I had
girlfriends you know and yeah that was
part of experimenting I think and not
that I was like oh trying to be gay for
fun no like I just felt attraction to
these people and there was like I guess
being so tied up in Mexico here not
being tied up at all was like [ __ ] it
like I like her and she likes me she's
my girlfriend like we're together and it
was a it was 2 or 2 relationships and
they were beautiful you know and it was
dope and now I don't really find myself
attractive
it too like women in that way but I can
say that I tried it and it was awesome
you know so I guess to me like I always
see myself as a free spirit so it's like
I want to feel and experience these
things that's and I did and I know and I
don't regret it you know it was
liberating for you it was awesome and
like just to think back and be like in
like my boyfriend now he's really
Mexican right so he doesn't like to know
about those things right he's like like
we're like Mexican you know and so like
the whole machismo thing I think still
plays part in that and so when we talk
about these things it's still a little
bit uncomfortable as opposed to like
someone who might be like a white dude
maybe I don't know or somebody who grew
up here like look at me I don't date
white white white man Slayer yeah like
people here might just be more open to
that you know and I have always just had
I'm very Americanized for a Mexican girl
you know I allow the feelings and
emotions to happen I supposed to you who
your mom got to you and was like no
[ __ ] I'm Batman additional I mean very
very very really hmm
but it's okay so now to turn it around
on you you've been in this relationship
do you feel like [ __ ] I wish I would
have had a couple one-night stands well
going like look like that type of regret
I don't have it but going like man that
would have been nice to try it that's
that's more the vibe like it's not a big
regret of mine where I'm like [ __ ] man
like like I'm gonna die and you never
get hot like it's more like oh man I
should have done it and bard and I have
even talked about it where like when we
get older we might just go and [ __ ]
be fighters or something yeah like it's
not the end of our life and he's really
open to talking about that so I'm like
let's try it that's dope
that's so what I say that right now and
I talk my big talk realm like it'd be
down to do it but if I'm put in the
situation I might [ __ ] out
do I feel like we're very similar in
that because I've had the same exact
conversation with my guy where I'm like
right now no nothing and I'm like but I
was like I'm open to the fact that in 10
years
things might get sale yeah I want to
introduce on the person we might want to
try some [ __ ] we'd never thought about
trying before you know I'm also very
possessive and I'm like don't you look
at my man you know you know like old
like old white rich people they get
bored after a while and they just want I
think everybody does [ __ ] but I read
this I read this on reddit post one time
about this couple they were like oh
we're in our early 30s were well-off
like and they they got like an escort
and they were like shoot like she costs
she was like a very like high-end like
escort they got a beautiful hotel room
and they were saying like they had this
beautiful night and I'm like yeah that's
what rich people do they're like let's
let's get us a hot girl tonight yeah
like one in you know and I was like I
feel like in ten years I probably do
that [ __ ] oh I'm sorry that was a loud
I'm actually surprised that you've never
had a one-night stand because you're
very open sexually like in our in the
previous podcast you talked about how
you had a threesome just yeah with
random people who had a threesome with
random people wouldn't you believe you
listen to the podcast oh it's my bad I'm
not behind this is like girl they put
saran wrap yeah so I had a threesome
with this couple they were like a couple
for like 10 years and I met them cuz I
was doing a fashion show and they were
there and the girl was drunk
long story short she's like I'm actually
a lesbian at heart I found out after 10
years with my man Wow they love each
other so much do you think that we can
so they invited me over to have dinner
first and then I actually got to know
them it was like a few days of like
hanging out and this and that and then
they kind of asked me so it wasn't like
a one night like first huh I miss yes
yeah yeah so it was really sweet as a
very it was actually a very uh it was a
very sweet thing he did for her and you
were able to okay so y'all just messed
around but he was into it too yeah he
was totally into it too like he we had
I'd sex with both of them but like for
me it was it was a more like like yeah
it was just like this is really sweet
that you're doing it first I felt like I
was
this [ __ ] even though like I will bring
you joy to your life I'm like hetero but
I never had a I really I actually really
did try to have a one-night stand once
cuz I never did oh please tell me about
that yeah and how did you try and how
did it not happen I was so curious I was
like I've never done this I was like 25
at the time and I shot with this
photographer and he was like fine like
he was this white guy with hella tattoos
I can tattoos and everything it was so
fine and we and it like this is the
first photographer I ever slept with
because it was like a big thing like
models don't sleep with ever like a
stigma but I was like dude he is so fun
and he's so nice yeah so we ended up
hooking up that night and I really did
try to make this one-night stand I was
like okay I'm not gonna spend the night
I'm out and I was kind of proud of
myself yeah yeah I'm going home I'm not
staying the night and then I couldn't
stop thinking about him and then we
ended up dating for like a year
oh oh I really did try but it didn't
wait so you had sex with him the first
day you met him uh yeah what does that
count that's a one night yeah that's not
a one-night stand but that's talking on
the first date yeah you you're getting
another one says we're gonna take a
quick break to introduce our next
bouncer guys a few weeks ago I had a
friend call me with the most
embarrassing story ever she was about to
get laid and he basically pushed her off
her because he said you should smell oh
no I told her you need Lola
that's right knock those cobwebs off
with Lola freshen that [ __ ] up yes Lola
is a lifesaver for someone like me now
uncomfortable with getting my period and
doing all that stuff but back in the day
I hated having to go to the grocery
store to buy tampons and stuff and this
is also yes Jess I know I'm [ __ ] old
okay so this is before people were comes
in I'm 87 shopping on the internet but
now we have we have Lola where you can
customize the bots that you want to get
every single month so you can get like
your friend she needs those edge wipes
yes the badge wipes they do send
you uh you can order different sizes of
tampons like you can have light-days
regular days heavy days they also do
have condoms and this is all sent to you
discreetly you don't have to worry about
it you don't have to stress about it you
can have a monthly subscription of just
them sending you whatever you can change
it every single month so it's
thoughtless now yes no matter what size
[ __ ] you got Lola got you covered what
I like is that it's organic materials
it's really high-quality materials it's
not bad yes they're about other brand
you know that corporate brand that
doesn't care about what they you know
are putting yet your [ __ ] and it's made
by a woman yeah solo that was created by
a woman and for all of our listeners are
now using to get 40% off all
subscriptions so yeah girl you can't
lose the disc oh it's deep is it so
visit my Lola comm and enter code b-tch
when you subscribe again that's my Lola
com enter b-tch when you subscribe to
get 40% off 40% off fight the pink tax
use Lola okay yeah so damn we lost the
traditionals last one see I almost
infuse because I thought it had to be
like a date-date like it is not go out
and oh I thought that's why I was saying
like yeah even though just meet them
right not even on a dish it I did it
yeah though like when you have sex with
ok so there's different kind of guys
right there's regular guys who like
aren't always [ __ ] girls who like
maybe it's even hard for them like they
probably get laid like once every so
often like yeah those are regular guys
like not the [ __ ] boys right and then
there's the [ __ ] boys right so what's a
[ __ ] boy I always hear the guys always
like they're just they know that you
know they the ones that text you why you
still awake
oh god the ones that are confident
enough and have done it enough times to
be like boom boom boom [ __ ] boys [ __ ]
boys they know that there's nine buttons
and they just know if they keep pushing
they know of inch the girls in the right
goody
okay go to EDC that the shirtless asian
guys with tons of tattoos there you go
really yeah maybe I'd just see past it
and I'm like man or white hair white
good hair that only works for some I
we're me okay Jess what we saying about
[ __ ] boy so I think if you're a girl and
you kind of like want to try [ __ ]
around just maybe don't do it with a
[ __ ] boy you could try with like a
regular guy why not cuz then well
because they're gonna treat you like
different than regular guys who you
sleep with on our first night III have
to contest that because if you [ __ ] a
fuck-boy you don't have to worry about
the aftermath if you [ __ ] a normal like
just guy that is a track yeah but though
at least you they'll be nice to you
after no they're gonna stalk you they're
gonna they're gonna really like you and
they're something that if you go too far
down the scale I think about regular
guys okay well I get what you mean
regular guys I think that it's it's
important than in that case to have a
firm conversation and say like hey what
is this so you don't lead them down the
wrong path
because like if if a guy that is like
not you know getting laid on a regular
basis like a fuck-boy he's gonna catch
feeling hot yes yeah so I think it's
like important for both parties like out
of respect for him and yourself to be
like this is what I'm looking for is
this cool with you I do but how do you
know this pose because it's
communication all right yeah like and I
believe but if you don't want to respect
him then just go for the [ __ ] boys even
they stand out like peacock and and to
add on to that I do have to say cuz I
have like I often talk to my
girlfriend's about this stuff who are
like dating still if you're gonna [ __ ]
with anyone whether it's a one-night
stand or not like make sure you get
yours because if you're in what he
didn't bet you get yours like because I
like the other day my friends like oh
yeah like I'm messing around with this
guy and like he's just like like 1 2 and
he's done and like he's like I mean like
hit it like 1 2 like to pump like this
you know and like it's funny that
because I'm like he's not giving you a
relationship he's not giving you money
he's not even [ __ ] taking you out
you're just coming over [ __ ] or
getting him off you're like a warm piece
of meat like you get yours and if he's
not getting yours like he should at
least be decent enough or steal
something [ __ ] it
they've got something yeah yeah take
this [ __ ] $40 on his watch
that was a joke fair about that is like
what you may not always realize I'm like
I'm not sure if your friend is
interested in him but when you like come
to a guy and you're like hey I want mine
to like that's attractive like a woman
that knows what she wants is attractive
to ya and if not don't [ __ ] them
yeah don't be afraid to tell him like
hey like I I need this this and this
because if anything he'll just be more
attracted to because like you're
confident you're coming out like you're
communicating with him and it will make
him want to communicate with you more -
all right yeah so I have a question for
the the ho bitch's pertain to you so
let's say me right
I come to y'all I don't pretend Bart and
Tyga don't exist in this world okay so I
come me but I come to you guys okay but
he doesn't exist you can you can see
what
um so when when I come to you like hey
y'all like I've been this traditional
[ __ ] and I'm tired of this traditional
life that I'm living I wanna I want to
try some new dick and I want real good
dick what advice you're gonna give me
like guys I've never done it what do I
do I'm gonna go out yeah we're gonna go
home yeah go up and go out put on it I'm
scared what if I'd like I catch
something like wingwomen right here yeah
and like oh never leave you you're gonna
have something deadly as long as you
wear condoms
yeah and the thing you have to remember
girl code ass [ __ ] you never leave your
friends now you're gonna go somewhere
and let's say we meet a group of dudes
and you're like I like that one all
right cool we hook you guys up kind of
we have to go with you like even if
we're not gonna do anything we go to the
house with you like we stay with you
like we don't leave you until you're
done you know and that's girl code as
[ __ ] that's it did you do that no um
well I usually will only went out with
like one other girl okay we were on the
prowl you know so it was either like
homie which team would she come back to
the house with sometimes yeah there was
one time where actually we were in the
same hotel room like there's two queens
- guys oh my gosh orgy room no but like
we weren't kind of flicking at the same
time like they would go into the
bathroom and they would come back and
then we would be like all quiet again
and like giggling under the covers and
then like just kind of [ __ ] her and it
was like kind of cute but we were in our
like mid-20
oh okay I as a professional wing woman I
have
laws on how to get laid at the club like
me like very simply you go out with your
girls everyone gets really hot has a
good time just like you know we did the
other night you know and just just go
out there dance do whatever and
eventually a guys probably gonna
approach you talk to him a little bit
you know like spark up the conversation
and then kind of walk away dismiss him
whatever and then watch this
[ __ ]
he's he talking to every girl at the
club or is he attracted to you like are
you the girl that he's looking at if you
don't see him like mingling with other
girls and like trying to but it in the
conversations go right back to him yeah
because he thinks he lost you and then
you come back and in a [ __ ] fire way
yeah that's a good that's a good doing
it but I know what's up I think we have
a good group of wing women here you know
yeah whatever happened oh absolutely but
if it was your first time doing it and
you're like alright I really want to do
it tonight and let's say we went all the
way through and then the last second you
were like alright I was just [ __ ]
kidding I'd be like alright that's fine
let's go home you know I think your
friend I have your back you know and if
if it's not in you you don't have to
force it out yeah you know listen always
happen like when you want it to so like
you I think for me like I was able to
have a lot of like what are you cleaning
our table with yeah it's like that's why
I was able to have a lot of one-night
stands because I went out so much so I
was going out like every single weekend
and then it wouldn't be successful every
single weekend you know what I mean like
obviously I was like on the prowl a lot
yeah but like only once out of every
like three months would I actually find
a guy that I connect with that I
actually want to go look like right away
like so it takes a little OTT it's like
a lot of work to actually have a
one-night stand because like it takes I
mean if you have standards it's like
it's hard to like actually have a good
one-night stand because like I would see
a ton of guys all the time and then just
it would be months before I found one
that I really wanted oh yeah how do you
guys feel about tender I've never been
on it I'm just very really i I've I've
gone on going on two dates on tinder and
this was like really all one it's hard
because half the people might recognize
Who I am oh yeah an influencer yeah yeah
so if they message me and say oh hey
it's you oh I'll just be like I'm gonna
delete them and then I'll just be like
oh it's a fake profile on a me I
to put mine like a fake name and then I
used to just put my pictures and people
would be like there's like a fake girl
on tinder trying to be like yeah report
her like you know and then I would not
like have a fake ass name all the way
through and then people would ask me
what I do I would be like like coach
crossfade like I would say my old job
because I didn't like if you already
know who I am from the internet like I
feel like you're gonna treat me
different you know so yeah I would
always take one sided because they
already know more about you yeah yeah
people know who I am now so I'm gonna
make this one why don't go through that
there's also the weird fear of somebody
knowing hey this is like an actual thing
that not somebody I know but it's
happened in LA that they know who you
are but they don't tell you and then
they buck you and they report it doing a
[ __ ] yeah yeah scary I've only
gone on a good point too and this is
like a while back when I was trying
cinder for the first time I just don't
feel that it's organic and all my tinder
it says I'm not looking a date I just
want because I like meeting people and
I've met a couple really cool people
like one dude he's like this really
sweet guy with a cute little puppy
and like we remain friends and we still
talk here in there and then waits here
just on tinder to meet guys yeah like I
know what's the bit why tinder why not
just like I like to swipe at people like
oh you're good looking and then are you
like judging him oh yeah I don't even
stay on my profile like yo if I I'm here
like sometimes I swipe people just to
compliment you so I'm just gonna
compliment you in a dip because I just
like I have this thing where I like
looking at people and I like dipping
myself into your life a little bit sure
you're about and then I dip out you know
cuz I'm curious about the patron saint
of compliments but I'm curious about
humans in general like people watching
and all that you know and I've met a
couple people that are really cool and
never slept with them and they were just
like they became friends and they're
awesome dam that's tight of you holy
[ __ ] or I'll find my own friends like
I'll try my to find my own friends and
I'll swipe on them and I'll I'll one bar
them like you'll send me dick pics right
now dude I met my I met my boyfriend on
tenor her boyfriend yes yes I split in
so fast I was like you like math that
was your life was your life I was like
yeah you like that oh my god I want to
hear everyone's like I see a
mathematician
when am i go to tender line yeah yeah
that I used to use and like it's funny
because I found a screencap of when he
and I first message and it was like all
these different dudes names but his in
the middle because I was messaging a
bunch of dude it's like because I can
like talk same line know do my copy
paste it if it's a [ __ ] boy I'm telling
this [ __ ] works it's like hey Mark
you're really hot but you look clingy I
mean a medium I like how the [ __ ] do I
look clingy I'm like no I'm just getting
cleaned off of you like that line works
on [ __ ] boys so Wow
amazing what it would have been some of
your lines no I don't use lines I don't
use thank you he does she seems like a
hey girl just like a hey I just like
walk up to them or something or they'll
walk up me and I was be like hey yeah
there is this one time this guy on
tinder like like I said compliments
right I felt bad for him because his
profile says just looking to [ __ ] just
divorce broke I don't even want to you
know like I'm just what's the [ __ ] and
yeah right and then he's like and you
know my life's a mess right now but I
hope it gets better me being the patron
saint right I messaged him I I matched
him I was like yo I don't want to meet
up and [ __ ] but I just want to tell you
I hope your life gets better
like I realize you wasted his time yeah
literally I gotta [ __ ] you did that to
me I'm your father and you're your hot
ass yes me and they're like hey hope
your life I would have instantly blocked
your ass back right yo this was like
three paragraphs he's like that's so
[ __ ] up you don't want to [ __ ] yeah
this is what you know what this is why
Trump is running America so bla bla and
I was just like [ __ ] that's why your
divorce broke [ __ ] we did a 180 oh you
can be like he's pissed right you see
well yeah I guess y'all the compliment
yeah and they want to still be like that
[ __ ] you don't want to [ __ ] you
well you can't afford anything well you
can't afford to be a [ __ ] like this
right he probably if he was at least
somewhat attractive he probably got a
lot of girls because there's a lot of
he'll [ __ ] oh yeah the fixers like
we're feeling
I don't know this these term now what
are you girls that are so like they they
need they feel like they need some
purpose and their purpose is like I can
like I can [ __ ] this dude and like be
important it's like I can fix him it
comes from arrogance - from what I
noticed really girls are like I'll be
the one that he changed yeah fixed
because I'm that special like nah boy it
works sometimes because I've been in
that position yeah I actually thought
that it came from insecurity because it
like makes you feel needed yeah yeah
maybe some assigned - there's the other
thing
never your job to fix anyone they need
to fix their damn cells but if you think
if you're gonna put yours if you're
gonna be of doormat so that you can fix
somebody else you need to fix yourself
first like you need to find your valid
doormat though cuz like there was this
cop that I was dating
oh yeah the cuff [ __ ] don't forget
forgot you [ __ ] a cop yeah so he was
he was emotionally broken someone in the
comments someone in the comment says or
what do you guys said it guess who's a
cop [ __ ] and someone goes obviously
Gina and I was like I can't wait so like
in a couple months from now your entire
like reputation is gonna hurt paid yeah
your followers are gonna drop yeah she's
not like the least Hoey on my Instagram
I'm gonna state it here right I'm a
boring ass [ __ ] of the ho yeah I just
talk a lot like I sound like a ho that's
all no you look like a ho I look like I
do I'm someone I'm your neighbor I'm
your friendly neighborhood just looks
like oh yeah yeah okay well yeah I don't
think every woman that does the whole
fixer thing is is being a doormat
because I think when I was doing it with
the cop like he was emotionally broken
like from being a cop he was emotional
right from police officers good yeah so
he was just like sad a lot and like but
he I'd never
like a doormat but it was like he had
emotional issues like I could see like
every time I went on a date like he's
not emotionally available he's not
emotionally available he said I'm gonna
but then like we would still have great
sex and all of that but then like every
time I would feel like he would want to
get close to me he would he would like
go back in his shell yeah so like I knew
like he needed to be fixed and I was
like oh I can fix his [ __ ] I can
fix him but then after a while I like
got bored of it right but it's not being
a dorm up yeah I think I was a fixer too
and I would and like now that I'm not a
fixer anymore I see myself as being a
doormat because I got nothing out of
that yeah and I think you like when you
don't love yourself and you're like I
[ __ ] it like I'll do whatever like I'll
take the punch like I'm here for you
what do you need you're crying I'll hug
you whatever you're just you weren't in
love with the Deuter you weren't like
you were like man this is [ __ ] boring
I'm out you know what I mean I supposed
to someone like a boza saying like who
needs that validation you're like I'll
stay I'll ride that [ __ ] out until
you're okay you know so that's the
difference like maybe you just weren't
emotionally invested to do I just
thought it was really hot so like I
wanted to be the one that like I mean
but I was dating other people at the
same time yeah ador I wasn't like yeah
you you it didn't hurt me that he didn't
get fixed yeah because you were getting
yours which was you know the hot guy
yeah because that's all you want yeah
yeah doormat you're right for fixers if
if he say you do fix him honestly what
is that doing for you it's fulfilling
this false this false insecurity that
you have that you like this whole this
void maybe make me feel better about
myself in that like I could fix a guy
yeah it makes you feel better but that
feeling is fake and it's fleeting it's
not real genuine confidence it's not
really feeling that void so to an extent
you are just being stepped on and you're
letting yourself be stepped on I didn't
feel stepped on though you know what I
mean like it's all that matters is how
you feel at the end of the day and if
you felt like you came out of it and it
was destructive and it hurt you like
that was that obviously not a good
situation but if you came out of it
you're like I I remember that that [ __ ]
was fun like he wasn't emotionally
available for me but I was also [ __ ]
another guy yeah it was like I wanted to
fix him because I felt bad for him as a
cop yeah like he was emotionally so
broken from seeing all the [ __ ] he got
to see every day
so I felt like a mother maybe a little
bit so I like it made me feel good about
my yeah it's fine I mean as long as you
were intact at the end then it's good
yeah I was going to act but I think the
fact that you're seeing some other guys
- you weren't hopefully invested in this
guy and some girls will give one guy
their every four years and it's called
codependency yeah that's literally what
it is when you're codependent if someone
else who has bigger issues than yours
like drug addict yeah laughs yeah I got
eggs you know yeah and then it's to the
point where you're like I don't give a
[ __ ] about me as long as you're okay
like who gives a [ __ ] about my job who
gives a [ __ ] about my family yep as long
as you're okay I don't really care what
happens to me and ladies [ __ ] that that
I feel like a lot of people go through a
short phase where they may do that and
then like but it's well guys go through
it too
really yeah I think a lot of guys yeah I
think it's just a person type thing I
don't think it's a gender thing yeah
that's fair that's absolutely I know a
lot of people who are savers like my
friend he's a saver and he admits it -
like one time you see me cries like Gina
don't cry in front of me you know much
how to save you right now but yeah
they're like some guys do that too and
it's just like I don't for me personally
I can't do that anymore because I used
to love guys like that it's like yeah I
do want to fix you because I want to
feel special I'm the one that you change
for or players right yeah there's always
a player's you're like I'm gonna be that
special one that ties them down and then
after a while I'm like nacho girl yeah
and like the worst thing about it is
it's so important to remember is you're
putting your self worth it which is I
fixed this guy I'm worth something
you're putting it in another person you
know and now you don't roll it your
self-worth it's not centered in you
anymore it's over there it's with him
and it's all tied to him in the minute
he's gone the minute he looks at
somebody out you what your self-worth is
gone yeah it's very it's a very immature
thing to do that's not that's like I
kind of I can kind of look back like
with kind of a smile at the [ __ ] that I
did when I was in my early 20s like and
you're exactly right about a lot of that
stuff that's not a grown woman thing to
do if you're like 35 and you're still
trying to do this [ __ ] like you need to
go to therapy there's like a lot of [ __ ]
wrong with you but like damn there's
like some help
is like when you're 1819 like yeah those
are the life lessons you have to learn
like it's okay if you're doing that
right now like you can stop that [ __ ]
right now
tomorrow I mean because you way to know
who you are yeah go through it and on
it's okay to do it it's okay I agree
like and it's better than us telling you
like not to touch the stove because it's
hot like you're experiencing but we're
being like hey you need to learn for
your own self you need to know you need
to go through it I think it's a really
important message to like you need to
learn all these things sleep with
whoever you want to sleep with and
sleeping the people does not diminish
your self-worth yeah responsible yeah
you just say don't don't like being a
crack house and sleeping with everyone
for four rocks you know but like
everyone does has have to go through
that learning process and I don't want
people to feel like well I slept with
this guy in my 20s and just like it made
me feel terrible it's like you're still
learning and that's okay you know yeah
many people as you as you want if you're
still learning about yourself and yeah
yeah Dan that was such a beautiful
message to end this pod come on holy
[ __ ] we start we went from like who's a
whole in this group love yourself know
who you are
live life forgive yourself for guys and
girls yeah this is for everyone and
Stacy thank you so much for being on
this podcast is a lot of fun and I also
want to thank our sponsors again so
thanks again to our wonderful sponsors
they're so wonderful I'm Dora - and Lola
right now our listeners can get five
dollars off their first order of 15 or
more when you download the door - app
and enter promo code b-tch so for 40%
off all subscriptions visit my Lola comm
and enter promo code b-tch when you
subscribe so thanks to everyone with
babbity okay so thanks to everyone who
wrote us on iTunes this week if you
haven't yet will you leave us a review 5
stars on one yeah I will find you yes
she will do she will talk to you and if
you're watching this on youtube you know
what to do smash that like button leave
a comment hit subscribe and
skies I'll leave comments tell us you
had a one-night how do I don't yeah
about it yeah yes okay with us cuz we
actually do read that I'm hit subscribe
and then ring that Bell yeah thank you
guys so much and check out our
individual socials at miss Gina darling
that's mi SS GI na darling yeah mine is
geo underscore Antoinette you guys can
figure that out
and mine is at Stacy BS Apodaca Big Boss
Bo's oh yeah finds like the old school's
shitty Instagram handle just underscore
Michele five one two but I'm gonna
change it pretty soon last name might
change this year to you check the link
in the description box below for all of
our socials I think we're gonna have
those down there oh my god I want to
hear this alright thank you guys see you
guys next to and shout out to you for
putting me on your old friend out thank
you